underneath that heading what I'd love
you to do is
could you please jot down this is
something we did in question two it's to
be it's just one part of it
could you just jot down this equation
again please there's a very good chance
you have working like it in your page or
any but you might not depending on what
question you got up to now I did flag
this before but I just want to state it
again so it's really clear right what
you are doing
during the quick questions when we
started was you went from here from the
left hand side to the right and we gave
that process today we called it starts
with an e expanding thank you very much
that's expanding but sometimes we
actually do want to have things you know
expand it out sometimes having brackets
is very useful so sometimes we will do
the reverse process and that reverse
process is called factorize you okay so
expanding gets rid of brackets factorize
e adds the brackets here does that make
sense
expanding get rid of Achatz factorize e
adds them in now for the next bit while
I write a few things up I'd actually
like you as I'm writing just turn your
computer on and boot it up because that
way by the time I'm finished talking
you'll be ready turn on and boot it up
but let's think about some examples
[Music]
okay so your computer is opening up but
you don't need to speak you don't need
to look at it I just wanted to be
booting up so it has time to prepare
while working on this together so
underneath where you've right written
that example of this is what expanding
looks like this is what factorize it
looks like here's what it looks like
when you haven't been shown before what
it looks like this is no brackets we're
going to factorize here we're gonna add
some brackets in and as the name
suggests factorizing what you need to
know is what are the common factors
between the objects that you're trying
to factorize okay let me say that again
what you're searching for is a common
factor between the two things you're
trying to factorize so this hopefully
will remind you from last lessons when
you think about 48 and 10a what's the
biggest number that can factorize into
both the biggest yeah it's just 2 in
this case isn't it they're quite large
numbers but the biggest one that I
actually share in common is just two and
one of the ways you can know that is as
soon as you write down this factor at
the front right I'm gonna write a pair
of brackets that's what factorizing
introduces and then I divide each of
these by two right I kind of we call
this I'm gonna take out a factor of two
and put it out the front okay
so when I divide this one by two I get
24 and when we divide 10 a by two I will
get five a very good now
you can make sure that you can't have
gone any further you couldn't have
picked any bigger numbers because you're
like oh I don't see any common factors
between these two except for one but
that's not very useful putting one out
the front doesn't change anything okay
now have a look at this next one okay
now for starters let's just think about
the numbers we'll come to the
pronumerals in a minute marek what's the
biggest number that you see fine very
good now first we'll write down that
five okay as you'll see in a second
there's gonna be more work to do but
that's okay I'm taking out a factor of
five and I write my true brackets here
and I divide each one but I find out
Merrick you just gave us the loss answer
so let's see if we can get someone else
to give us the next step
okay so handy yet tell me what to do
next what happens we divide this guy by
five okay sit now yeah yeah we're gonna
get to that MINIX line right now what
have we done here we took out a factor
of five so I've divided everything on
this side by 5 and that gave me what's
inside the brackets but in this case
unlike the previous one I can do more
Jessica what do you see
okay so just pause that for a second
Jessica hold that thought
think about what we're doing here right
we're trying to find the biggest factors
we can take out we took five that is the
biggest number but a is also a number
isn't it it's a proneural I just don't
know what the number is
okay so I can take out five I've already
done that I can also take out this a
that Jessica is suggesting and then I'll
have something even simpler left in here
okay Louise you wanna tell me what's
right next oh yeah go ahead I'm gonna
ask
and like five yep and you can write five
but in this one yep so why did I write
two here is that the question yeah okay
so oh yeah it's about it's always about
the biggest number I can find right
let's think about this right so if I had
written down I'm just gonna write it in
another color you don't need to make a
stone if I've looked at the first line
I'd say oh I can take out one I'm gonna
do the same thing I've been doing every
other time right I'm gonna divide this
by one which gives me 48 and then I'm
gonna divide this by one which gives me
ten a now this is a true statement it's
true it just isn't very useful because
it's kind of like but I already knew
that
that hasn't changed what I've got here
any any more it hasn't made a simpler
does that make sense
so you can't do it it just doesn't lead
anywhere Krishan yes okay we're gonna
get to the negatives in the next one if
that's okay because they are a bit
sneaky and tricky I've deliberately been
giving you mostly positives we'll have a
look at the next one okay is that all
right now we're not quite done here
right can someone help me out I'm
looking at these guys I'm dividing each
one by a okay Jessica you give me what
you know one just have a look at that
with me because that was a bit weird and
different okay boys you still with me
thank you of it so you can see what
we've done right we took out the five
and then we like well wait I can keep
going I can take out a as well what do
you think it is can we go any further
hmm
so here's what I call things right just
put your pens down for a minute and look
up when you were in when you're in
primary school right and someone said to
you can you and I'm not a rhetorical
question can you tell me what five take
away three is you all would have said
two right because one two three four
five you can take away three objects one
two three and then you get left with two
right and I had someone asked you
primary school you hey can you do three
take away five primary school you should
have responded you can't do that because
how can you take five away from this
right you're like well you take away one
and then you take two and then you take
away three and then I've got no more
stuff to take away right but high school
you knows that three take away five can
be done right you can say oh I know what
negative numbers are so you have an
answer for this I do agree with that and
what happens it's the more that you know
that why the kind of problems you can
solve now at the moment this is totally
fine give it a big tick okay this is
perfect right but as you go forward
you're actually going to learn how to
you can factorize this as well you can
take a common factor out I'm going to
teach you how to do that a little bit
later on okay but for now that's all we
can stop all right can you write that in
example three for me now this is when
we're going to get to croissants
questions because he was talking about
negatives right at least we're gonna
start to answer it so here's what I'd
like you to put down what am I gonna
give you I'm gonna give you this
actually I'm really yeah them do okay so
this is staying to look a little Messier
isn't it now when you have a look at
this right I'm gonna ask the same
question that I've been asking all the
way through and you might notice you
know it's nice if you could look at this
and you can say oh I can get five a
immediately then go there you don't have
to do it in two steps but often it takes
some time to like recognize what other
things you can take out so it can
someone named for me just a single thing
that they can take out okay Jessica
watch you hold that thought you give
them a few answers which is great
who else can give me a suggestion hmm
Tim what do you see Tim one should have
liked the Apple three have a look at the
numbers have a look at the protein rules
can you pick a number out any number
that's a common factor between these two
David can you come out can you see a
number that you can divide into this and
you can divide into this as well any not
be like probably four four words for me
let's start with that okay you might be
able to think of another one or concert
a minute let's divide by four okay and
what will get more suggestions in a
second let's do four first okay four
words to suggest you know we're not
under that okay when you divide negative
48 by four what do you get watch out
you've got negative 48 right so you're
gonna get negative 12 okay now I'm gonna
do the next one negative 36 XY squared
that'll be - I'm dividing this by four
aren't I so I should get nine what
happens to the premiere rules X Y sweat
nothing's changed
okay now some of you had your hands up
even after David suggestions number
because you're like oh I can do more
right Harry what did you see
I can see 12 now I can take 12 out from
here but at the moment over here having
done David suggested step Jessica
having done David suggested sip I can't
divide these guys by 12 anymore right
this one's too small so what can I do is
there vishakha I get to 3 right 3 will
go into 12 and it'll go into 9 so when I
push pins down for a second this knit
you need to look up look up look up look
god do you remember what we went from 5
to 5 a did you notice that we took out
the a and you're like oh now I've got
the 5 and the a at the front now I've
already got a 4 and the shark is
suggesting that I also take out a 3 so
instead of having 4 at the front I'm
gonna have the four and the three
together so that gives me 12 which is
actually that number that has suggested
in the first place
okay so can you highlight that for me
because once you've already taken out
one number when you take out another one
they sort of collect at the front okay
alright now we're taking you out three
what will happen with this minus 12 when
you divide it by 3 yeah here your 4
thank you very much I'm gonna divide
this by 3 as well what are you gonna get
sure very good okay
now at this point the pronumerals is
nothing much that we can do with those
pretty rules the numbers look pretty
good 4 & 3 are very small right but
there's one more thing we can do which
will be even better than both of these
see how there's a negative here and here
there's two of them right and I'm like I
don't like negatives they're gross I
want to write as few negatives as I can
because negatives are easy to confuse so
I'm gonna do one last thing I'm gonna
take out negative 1 okay yeah right
everybody everybody picked it right it's
like that feeling like I knew that was
the bad guy okay so if I take out a
minus sign if I take out negative 1 then
negative 4 will not be negative 4
anymore it'll be positive 4 right just
regular old for this minus 3xy squared
will not be minus anymore it'll be
positive plus now
just before I show you or I actually let
you loose on some of the textbook
exercises one of the great things that
all of these questions is have a look at
example one two and three
your final line is this factorized thing
this factorized thing you can always
know whether your factorization is or is
right by checking it really simply
because you're very good at expanding
this is a Scooby working on for a while
so you could take this you can expand it
will take you back here you could take
this you'd expand it where take you back
yeah does that make sense you can do it
all the way through